alicia let me throw this video quick
because you mentioned uh the u.s
volleyball olympian her name is kim
glass uh who was attacked in downtown
l.a so let's just throw to that real
quick this was in downtown los angeles
daylight right and out of nowhere you
get sucked by a 10-inch bolt
and i i just have to think when when you
think back on that it has to there has
to be some something in your mind that's
saying how
why in the world did that happen
and when you ask yourself that how do
you answer it
you know
i sat with it i was thinking about it in
the ambulance as i was talking to my mom
on facetime
and i was like mom
i don't know why this happened to me and
and i was like i i there's nothing i
could have done to prevent it you know
like i think sometimes we get really
we feel like kind of immune when we're
walking in the daytime right regardless
and
i think about what i could have done
and i don't
for me i i feel like i'm always alert
and i there's nothing i could have done
to prevent this you know i know
everyone's out there offering me
self-defense classes and how'd you let
him get close to him like he wasn't
close and i could have never predicted
this happening and there's been other
victims around los angeles and it keeps
on happening and
and everyone's paying attention to me
because i'm an olympian right but these
other attackers haven't been um the
other victims haven't been vindicated
right every time someone's being let out
on the street again and again
they're doing a disservice and they're
pretty much saying that
these victims traumas were in vain at
this point what's the answer
you know because something everything
that we're doing right now
is not working yeah well there needs to
be a change a lot of evidence a lot of
an answer frankly um
comes from people like you when you go
public i just hope that god leads me
and is like
gives me the right words or
just leads me in the direction that's
where everyone's high is good
sorry we wish you because you know
i didn't expect all this through the tv
camera to you kim we're praying for you
alicia i'm going to guess that most
people watching this right now uh did
not see that well they don't watch cnn
and msnbc and the rest of it anyway but
i'm going to guess that that didn't make
it to cnn and msnbc i mean a young a
young black woman gets assaulted i mean
those bruises were serious that was a
serious bash to her face i thought we're
supposed to care about this sort of
thing but uh seemingly only fox cares
about it what's going on here it is
interesting there's there's even been
some stories when i mentioned earlier
all of the mad moms that are saying no
you're not going to mask our kids again
no you're not going to do coveted
lockdowns again the largest business
group here in l.a county has told the
the county superintendents we're not
doing this again you're choosing
people's livelihoods and lives are at
stake we're not doing this again and
only conservative outlets are covering
it why because it doesn't fit the
mainstream media narrative is that the
government is the best and they're the
end-all be-all god bless her for
speaking up as i mentioned i've had
friends that have been assaulted and
stalked by homeless people i love the
flower market it's my thing but i no
longer take my girls down there because
there are so many encampments that you
can't even street park anymore the
sidewalks and the streets are full and i
feel for these people but people like
the man that attacked her i will not use
his name because he doesn't deserve any
more media headlines he deserves to be
behind bars and i only wish that kim
would go a little further and speak out
for all of the victims and say you know
all the signatures are in i hope gascon
gets recalled there's a runoff between
karen bass and rick caruso it's pretty
obvious which of the two are going to be
a better choice for los angeles so i i
hope that more people see her story and
more people get involved because it's
not just the president that the is the
end-all be-all if kovid taught us
anything left right and center your
local races matter
and by the way we all know how this game
is played there is simply no doubt that
kim will soon be called alt-right and
everything else for having gone on fox
to discuss being bashed by a homeless
person because of progressive policies